if you say that a little kid can make
the informed decision to mutilate
himself
and to cut off his genitals we're told
certainly
that little kid can make the informed
decision to dance around for dollars
this is such a deeply unjust society
there's a video just put up by angela
stanton king who is a
right-wing activist this was apparently
the south beach area
lgbt club called palace the blaze
reported on this video where it's at
this drag bar
and they bring little kids up on stage
and have them
pick up the dollar bills that are being
thrown at them during this performance
take a listen
now i'm sitting here trying to figure
out why in the hell these people got
these
little
[Music]
11 40 at night these people have
children
in a drag show in l.a on the beach
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look look they giving them money yo
little girls now
look at this look at this
[Applause]
so we obviously blurred out the image we
don't want these little girls
faces to be out there uh and we we had
to bleep out the woman's commentary
but i actually wish we didn't have to
bleep out the woman's commentary because
although i i prefer not to use coarse
language in public i prefer not to go
blue
i think this woman is saying exactly
what we're all thinking
i think this woman frank if anything she
was being restrained
could you imagine if you you well i
guess you wouldn't be there right you
wouldn't be at some drag bar in south
beach that would have kids dancing on
the stage but
if you were and you saw that what would
you what must you think
this is such a deeply unjust society
that would permit this sort of thing and
yet
according to the logic of the left that
the left is pushing especially on this
gender issue
what's wrong with that well it's fun
it's nice it's open
it's tolerant it's liberating that these
little little itty bitty girls are being
treated or i don't know if they're girls
or they're boys or dressed like girls i
don't know i don't know i
didn't pay close enough attention to the
video and you shouldn't either let's
just call them girls
what's wrong with them being treated
like strippers and picking up the
stripping is empowering
what's being what's wrong with them
having dollar bills thrown at them
like they're like they're just meat
puppets you know like they're just flesh
we're just flesh that's all we all are
right what's wrong with them being
sexualized we're told
that little children three-year-old kids
ought to be able to make the decision to
castrate themselves
and to mutilate their bodies because
they know their true
sexual essence they have a deep sexual
nature
they are they are sexualized from the
very beginning
and they possess the ability to consent
to these sorts of things
right so we got to get rid of age of
consent laws
we have to if you if you say that a
little kid can make the informed
decision to mutilate himself
and to cut off his genitals certainly
that little kid can make the informed
decision to dance around for dollars
that's a that's a far less outrageous
sexual sort of decision surely that
little kid can consent
to sexual behavior if you're granting
the premise that the kid can castrate
himself
where is that there doesn't need to be a
coherence
there doesn't need to be a logic here
because with the left the left is
ultimately denying that in favor of
willfulness and interest if i want it
it is good that is ultimately what this
is coming down to and justice
never enters the equation whoa whoa whoa
whoa where are you going where hold on
you don't need to leave so fast
first please ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe that way you will never miss a
video that we put out
something tells me that sometimes
youtube would prefer it if you would
miss videos that we put out
so make sure you subscribe like really
appreciate it we'll see on the next
[Music]
you